the more we lead a life of I are I will
always be frustrated because people
don't exist in this world to just
fulfill your expectations once you learn
how to control the mind you really not
controlling the mind you controlling
awareness and where awareness goes in
the mind ultimate source of heavy life
this in event wanna be happy
build a life not a business
so today let's live your best believe
life and learn how to 10x your life with
these monk secrets secret number one
don't lead the life of I with Gallagher
Paul DAWs what is the most selfish one
lettered word I isn't everything
revolves around I I phone iPad iPod and
the man says I paid everything revolves
around the eye and what does I stand for
i stands for expectations I should be
treated like this
I should be loved like this I should be
dealt with like this I should be
respected like this I should be given
these many marks I should not be given
this at all leading a life of super high
expectations everything revolves around
my opinions my desires my likes my
dislikes I love this I want this I don't
want this
ai ai ai ai ai you think life will be a
very happy life when it revolves around
I
from our childhood we have grown up like
this you only learn to take and everyone
has to fulfill my expectations
everything has to be up to my
expectations therefore when people come
to God people come to a temple also
they're only asking give me what I want
no one comes to say I love you I wanna I
want to give you when the president of
the United States John F Kennedy came up
to a stage for his first presidential
speech his voice rumbled into the public
addresses too many said ask not what the
country can do for you ask what you can
do for the country and so we are saying
ask not what God can do for you ask what
you can do for God but no one asks that
because the eye is so big my
expectations my desires my things are so
powerful that even when I come to a
temple and ring the bell all I'm doing
is asking the more we lead a life of I
are I will always be frustrated because
people don't exist in this world to just
fulfill your expectations therefore
ladies and gentlemen the most selfish
one lettered word is AI which stands for
expectations and therefore avoid this
word how do you avoid this word be
realistic in your expectations apeksha
acronym a problem me but understand that
not everyone will fulfill your
expectation and secondly avoid this word
I by trying to serve others you know why
because when you want to be served you
dependent on people they may not serve
you when you want to serve who can stop
it when you want respect people may not
respect you but when you want to give a
respect who can stop you
really want to be loved you will not be
loved but when you want to give love who
can stop you when you want and charity
people may not give you in charity but
when you want to give charity who can
stop you and therefore learn to begin
your journey from i to you the more you
want for yourself you'll remain
frustrated the more we want to give you
will remain happy secret number to
control your awareness with dhandapani i
think understanding the - one of the
most important things anybody could do I
always tell people that's the one thing
that we don't have a manual for
everything else in life we animated
right yeah your clothing has manual
there's a tag in the back tells you how
to wash it yeah food blenders come with
manuals cameras but the mind doesn't and
from among experiential learning the
best the simplest way to understand the
- to understand the difference between
awareness and the mind so imagine your
minor as a map with different areas some
areas of your mind that's angry happy
sad jealousy odd signs food sex sports
and awareness is a glowing ball of light
that floats around in your mind and
wherever it goes in your mind it lights
up that area when it lights up that area
you become conscious of it so yo
awareness this glowing ball of light is
always being pulled from one area of the
mind to another by people and things
around you yet through the notification
goes off you know Anna's goes to trigger
of the mind and then you see a facebook
notification though awareness goes over
there and the phone rings that awareness
goes over here so all day people allow
people and things around them to pull
their awareness from one thing to
another once you learn how to control
the mind you really not controlling
their mind your controlling awareness
and where awareness goes in the mind now
you can keep allowing us on one thing at
a time and remain concentrated so now
how can we get control that word so how
can we practice to get better at
enjoying our work the best way to do
this is to integrate the practice into
so I feel that if you're practicing just
example meditation in the morning for 15
minutes or half an hour is completely
useless if their remaining 23 and a half
hours of the day you're doing something
that's kind of productive
yeah so I believe the best way to make
progress and most efficient way to make
progress is to actually integrate the
practice into everything that you're
doing yeah so for example every time you
speak with your lovely spouse give her
undivided attention so keep your
awareness and your spouse s your
awareness drifts away bring your
awareness back to your spouse you dress
away again reinfected spouse yeah so
with everything you do keep your eye on
it do one thing at a time and the more
you practice this the better you get at
it also if you want to learn how to have
more confidence check of my 254 series
they're free the links aren't in
description below it's easy to make a
buck very hard to make a difference it's
quite amazing how we work ourselves up
so much with increasing the standard of
living that we forget to increase the
standard of our life and whenever you're
updating to a higher version of your
self you have to be able to give the
best of yourself to it secret number
three tap into the way of the universe
with Jay Shetty I was looking at life
and going what do I want my life to be
about and I swore successful people who
were depressed I saw rich people who
were sad and I swore famous people who
in the end had to find a new way of
getting happy and just this week as
we're talking we saw what having a Kate
Spade and Anthony Bourdain and rest in
peace to both of them and you know
blessings and best wishes and prayers
for both of them yeah and then billion
hundred millions a lot of people in the
world that we don't know about like in
the people that we don't talk about and
we don't see because they're not famous
and well-known at 18 I was awakened to
the belief and understanding that if I
did not focus on my consciousness there
was no such thing as happiness and
meaning if I didn't go inward there was
no chance of longevity in any form
because I saw all of this around me so
what I swim the monks I was different is
that they almost had
act in to the way of the universe and
I'll explain what I mean by that what I
mean is that if you observe the universe
carefully every element in the universe
is constantly serving constantly the
water provides us with energy the trees
provide us the nutrition the oxygen is
just fueling our bodies and it's taking
nothing from our yeah you look at the
tree when you take shade of a tree the
tree doesn't say that will be two
dollars yeah right the teeth it might
think about this all the time in the air
I really yeah yes it's it's so many
things now we're bottling up air and
selling it but the point being that
there is every element the Sun is giving
light yeah and it's growing our plants
and vegetables the rain is growing our
plants and vegetables are given every
element in the universe is serving and
what I learned as a monk and when you
speak about this and we just experienced
it so deeply when we were there is the
only way to be aligned with the universe
is to serve because then you're acting
in alignment because the universe is
serving so when you're serving you are
now in the universe you're not with the
universe the universe is your ally
whereas as long as you're trying to
serve yourself and be greedy
you're not working against the universe
so when people talk about like the
universe has your back or you should
work with the universe will be aligned
with the universe that's what it means
University isn't about all universe I
want a big car like give it to me that's
not being a land of the universe right
being around er the universe is choosing
service right as your focus secret
number four pay attention to your inner
values with the Dalai Lama ultimate
source of happy life
it's our inner value
so therefore irrespective whether
believer or non-believer whether
believers religion or not see we should
pay more attention about our inner value
now scientists lost according latest
scientific findings it now
sort of clear the even good health or
healthy body the healthy mind is very
essential more peaceful mind brings
healthy body because mind calm peaceful
then our healthy our body sort of
element also you see then remain more
balanced so that brings healthy body and
Troy's stress towards worried disturb
our body element that creates certain
sort of problems about his body so
therefore our mind it's very essential
and secret number five the last one
before a very special bonus clip is be
open to the mystery of life with tick
not high when people look at the cosmos
look at the planets and look at life in
different forms they ask the question
what is the meaning so everyone is
trying to find a meaning of life the
meaning of life is not something
objective edifying but that is our way
to look and to find a meaning
if I believe that if you you have you
have an idea about the meaning of life
[Music]
you may be caught in that idea so you
should all out just have to be open in
order to continue to get in touch with
the wonders of life and you will
discover more and if you have already an
idea about meaning of life that may that
amount may be a kind of obstacle for you
to go more deeply that it is possible
for you to to be fully present in order
to in order to be in touch with all
wonders of life and that has a capacity
to to nurse you to heal and by doing so
you might deepen your understanding of
the mystery of life but if you live in
such a way that that brings so much
craving and anger and despair you will
lose yourself and you miss the chance in
order to to be in the here and now and
that you know got to be in touch with
the wonders of life now I've got a
special bonus clip with done the pani on
how to be focused at I think you're
gonna enjoy but before that is some for
the three-point landing question it's
time to go from just watching a video to
taking action here we go
question number one how will you stop
leading the life of I question number
two how will you control your awareness
and your thoughts this week and question
number three what does tapping into the
universe looked like for you my goal was
to to have my own business to be an
entrepreneur and make my own money and
had you been thinking about it while
you're in the monastery yeah the last
well not all those years the last couple
years deciding whether I wanted to leave
was probably the
they probably was the hottest decision
I've ever made in my life was to leave
them on the street yeah so the next
question to be what would I do
could have ran a web business from the
monastery we we had the largest web site
in the state of Hawaii
yeah monks programmed in hits DML CSS
JavaScript and we were trained how to
edit movies when Final Cut Pro design
and InDesign Photoshop we knew it inside
out Wow
yeah I I learned coding in the monastery
oh that's awesome I didn't know well I
thought I literally thought you were
preparing for meditation we we took
those concentration skills into
everything that we did so when we were
programming we focused on programming
you know when we we were building a
building we were putting cement on the
sidewalk or sweeping something or
cooking we're focused so in everything
that we did throughout the day we
practiced all the tools that we learned
so when we sat to meditate we'd been
practicing for 23 all day all day yeah
if you want to learn the five morning
routines that are critical for success
check out the video right there next to
me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there person that doesn't use the snooze
alarm so there's a rule there's 30
minutes I cannot touch my telephone when
I wake up that's the hardest thing to do